for the first time in his young career
alec manoa will take on the tampa bay
rays
yeah this will be a challenge for alec
manoa this is a good raised team they
don't have the great numbers offensively
but they are pesky pesky hitters manoa
is 1-0 this year
but now there's a runner-up second on
the bark
you two pitch breaking ball swinging a
miss a little better depth on that
slider and manure gets a strikeout it's
not exceptional here's a 2-2 pitch he
came back with another change it what a
good start for alex noah
this is luis patino just called right
back up from the minor leagues to get
the start against the blue jays he's 1-1
this year with a 360 earn run average at
the end of may
though cuts it into the right field he
can do that i mean he can call his shots
when he gets to two strikes
another base hit for bo bashet so here's
george springer moving up into the
cleanup spot tonight
he goes after the first pitch and smokes
at the center
back it is gone
charlie montoya looks like a genius
moving springer up and he delivers a
two-run home run here in the first
cut and a miss by hernandez out on
strike springer hit the home run and
toronto takes a two-nothing lead so
here's lure to scurial again banning any
eighth spout
much different hitter this is going to
be trouble it's going to score one for
sure maybe two all the way up against
the wall in left as
they will stop bitching at third as
curiel drives in another run with an rbi
double
his 16th double of the season rbi number
33 and it's three nothing blue jays
[Music]
there's reese maguire the catcher with
runners at second and third and he goes
after the first pits and he gets a base
hit riching is in the score
guerrielle is being hurled at third base
as reece mcguire jumps on the first
pitch and picks up an rbi base hit
three and one decibion
he bounces this ball that's going to
score a run and if he can lay it out he
does
bang bang and guriel will come in it'll
be no rbi
for simeon
but he's going to wait and they're going
to have a look at it tough double play
that has to be turned by the race one
long throw and another one
simeon thought that maybe he would be
safe that's the future right there in
franco
and lau
with a strong arm to joy
and it looks like the blue jays are
contemplating what they want to do
i don't know from that angle right there
looked like that foot might have been on
the base
he didn't take a high step he kept his
foot low and he hit the front part of
the base
and he's going to be safe and he's going
to get himself an rbi thanks to that
hustle
he turns that fastball in that spot
he'll have a lot of success
he's set looking back at simeon
has the same spot that's a base hit to
right simeon is being waved around there
here's the throw to play
[Music]
scores ahead of the throw and it's six
nothing blue jays
struck out of rose arena last time on a
hard slide or away from it
goes upstairs with the heater right
there and strikes him out good fastball
for the strikeout that's eight
strikeouts now
swinging and miss the fastball got
rendered for a second time that's nine
strikeouts
three-two pitch
slider popped up playable on the infield
body guerrero the first baseman
territory makes the catch
another tree up three down inning
manoa in command
alec manoa has nine strikeouts tonight
and that ties him with sean reid fully
for the most strikeouts by a blue jay
stutter in the first seven major league
starts
trent thornton had 38 mark subchinskiy
had 37 but
right now alec manoa is tied with sean
reid foley at 42 he has nine strikeouts
through five innings including a stretch
of seven in a row which is a franchise
record for a blue jays pitcher seven
consecutive strikeouts
here's kevin kiermann
he goes after the first pitch and lines
it to marcus obsidian
that's a first well hit call by the
race that was a liner simeon was
positioned perfectly took a little
something off of that one a little get
me over off speed pitch
an atom ball right at the second baseman
gold glover right there can handle that
one
west virginia university
there's a fly ball into center field a
little shallow flying ball richard can't
make the play it's off his glove
mahia is headed for second
that'll be the first hit of the game for
francisco mejia and you can bet randall
grijic was aware of that you could tell
by the effort he understood what was at
stake on that little blooper
fastball head high in the air to right
field pay oscar's got room back at the
edge of the warning track he hauls it in
and that's the end of the inning
alec manoa ready to go in the first
pitch to wander franco is grounded
through the left side and into left
center field for a base hit
moving to his right to play it back into
the infield as grichik and on the first
pitch
of the seventh inning wander picks up
his first stick
up the middle and a base hit into center
field
franco makes the turn will hold its
second so wendell gets his base hit
[Applause]
seven innings in the book shutting out
the tampa bay rays on just three hits a
terrific outing for manoa his first
against tampa bay after the order for
the blue jays it'll be simian
[Music]
[Applause]
goes deep again
his 21st home run
to match his 21st double
and simeon just validating the fact that
he should be the american league starter
is second base
here's the 3-2 pitch
liner into lafayette and it's off the
club over rose arena
and bow's headed for second he puts the
brakes on and hustles back to first
it'll be another hit for boba shed his
second of the night body picked up an
rbi in the second he's one for three his
rbi number 67.
he hits this one high and deep to right
get out of here
an opposite feel the home run on a
breaking ball
and vladi guerrero drives in two more
runs with his 27th home run of the
season it's two and five against the
rays but toronto has dominated this game
tonight
ball lifted into right field and that's
going to one hop the wall hernandez
after it
he is going to score
and brandon lau gets the raise on the
board with the two base hit back-to-back
doubles by mejia
and lao the rays
have their first run of the night
it's a 10-1 ball game we move to the
bottom of the eighth in buffalo
[Music]
that's brett phillips out there we saw
him
in the bullpen and
he's about to make his first career
pitching appearance
here we go
interested to see the the delivery you
saw him working on
any number of them down
espinoza came in the game as a pinch
runner lasting and now he'll get a base
hit
so he drives one through the right side
simeon comes in to score and he'll stop
the runners there
so espinal gets an rbi in his first
played appearance of the game
11-1
says alec manoa is in line for his
second
major league win
a terrific
seventh inning effort
bouncing ball toward first guerrilla
step on the mag and that's the ball game
the blue jays win in game one of this
three game series in
big-time fashion they win 11-1 alec
manoa picks up his second major league
win